c'est dans cet hôpital de berlin qu'elle
excellait valny repose dans un coma
artificiel depuis presque lui selon ses
médecins allemands avaient déjà conclu
qu'il a été empoisonné
mais demander du temps pour déterminer
avec trois exactement aujourd'hui plus
de doute pour un gala merkel la preuve
est non seulement irréfutables elle est
troublant
alexeï navalni a été victime d'une
attaque menée avec un agents
neurotoxiques de la famille d'une audi
chao la chancelière le même poison avait
été utilisée contre l'ex espion sergueï
skripal et sa fille lors d'une attaque à
londres en 2018 pour un gala merkel il
est clair qu'on a voulu carnaval yeux
aussi
il existe désormais des explications du
kremlin immédiatement ces images sont
les dernières d'alexis navalni ansa
c'était à la mi ou à novossibirsk
sibérie où il menait une enquête sur la
corruption
al'approche des élections régionales
c'est lors du vol de retour à moscou
qu'il a su bien violent malaise on
l'entend sûrs les travaux perdre
connaissance
[Musique]
sa mère russe anastasia vaciller vent
est aujourd'hui catégorie est
opposition et pour vladimir caramanlis à
une autre cause un qui a lui même été
empoisonnés l'an dernier une cale
attaques luc avoir été orchestré par les
plus hautes sphères du pouvoir
pour le moment la russie nie toute
implication
sachez chine justement un stand hommes
ceux-ci disent les miss toi tu sais la
télévision ce soir la porte-parole des
affaires étrangères parlait de notre
campagne d information d'accusations
sans fondement ils refusent toujours
d'ouvrir une enquête criminelle à des
coûts d'une collaboration du kremlin
gala merkel a prévenu ce soir qu'elle
entend discuter avec ses partenaires de
l'otan et d'europe 10 suites à donner à
ce qu'il semble être une fois de plus l'
usage d'une arme chimique et cette fois
contre le plus célèbre est plus
important kitty
berne avant de vladimir
starace lascaux radio canada